this video is made possible by Brillion
you're gonna learn more about brilliant
later in today's video but if you'd like
to learn more about them right now go to
brilliant to log /by graphics you'll
also find a link in the description
below Jeremy Bentham was a man ahead of
his time
though not a philosopher he developed a
utilitarian philosophy based on the
doing of good to oneself and to others
he used it to propose fundamental
reforms to a system that he saw as
grossly unjust his ideas have
reverberate a down through the ages to
affect the world that we live in today
in the biographic sideo today we delve
into the life and the teachings of
Jeremy Bentham
jeremy bentham was born on the 15th of
February 17:48 in Houndsditch London the
Bentham's were a family of wealth and
income was derived from an extremely
successful pawnbroking enterprise from
generations past his parents James Nell
has spent their time in social and
intellectual pursuits young Bentham was
a child prodigy with his extraordinary
abilities becoming evidence very early
on by the age of three he was reading
fluently on one occasion when he had
just turned 3 he was walking in the
woods with his parents and some other
adults he became bored with the adult
conversation and decided to return home
as the adults were absorbed in their
conversation they didn't notice his
departure when they returned home the
adults found him sitting at a reading
desk absorbed in reading a book on the
history of England's Jeremy's classical
studies began at the age of four the
monk the journals of his father there
exists a piece of paper with the
following heart the line pasted Haran
was written by my son Jeremy Bentham on
the 4th of December 1753 at the age of 5
years 9 months and 19 days the line in
question well it was a long phrase in
Latin this document shows not only the
amazing talent of the child but also the
obvious pride that the father had in his
sons intellectual gifts in fact James
was constantly bragging about the genius
that lay within us boy that age for
Jeremy was learning both the Greek and
the Latin languages james employed a
clerk and this man was given the duty of
teaching young james to write as well as
to read music and play the violin by the
age of 6 regular music tutor had been
employed and James with his miniature
fiddle became an adept violinist James
wanted for his son to excel at
everything when Jeremy was 7 he was
given dancing lessons it was something
that he absolutely detested the boy was
so weak that he wasn't able to support
himself on his tiptoes yet his father
repeatedly forced him to go through the
exercises becoming more exasperated with
every failed attempt when not absorbed
in his studies with his father Jeremy
loved nothing better than to spend time
at the country estates of his two
grandmother's at Browning Hill embarking
he was a lover of nature and would spend
hours exploring the flowers and the
trees on the family's grounds
[Music]
while young James was mentally superior
to his peers physically hey was anything
but it was much shorter than other
children of his age and was extremely
thin and weak when he was seven years of
age he began attending Westminster
School in London he immediately hated
the experience it being a far contrast
to the one-on-one instruction that had
been receiving all my senses birth he
later wrote Westminster was a wretched
place for instruction I was the least
boy in the school into the bigger boys
took pleasure in pitting us one against
another Bentham was entered into the
upper second form due to his obvious
advanced intellect he soon gained a
reputation as their little philosopher
as a result of his ability to reason and
consider every matter his skills in
Latin and Greek made him a valuable boy
to know and many of the other boys
leaned on him to provide homework
answers Bentham soon became a target for
bullies at the school however there was
one boy who served as a protector for
him if it wasn't for this companionship
he would have been the subjects of daily
humiliations and is all the years he
spoke with disgust at the fagging system
by which younger boys were subjected to
all manner of intolerant treatment he
was just as dismissive of the teaching
that was offered at the school saying
that he was taught few useful and many
useless things Bentham observed that the
high the rank of the professor that less
efficient the man was been vanassa
feared with the agony and boredom of
westminster for five years finally the
age of 12 he graduated and his father
enrolled in a Queen's College in Oxford
there was a remarkable achievement for
such a young man's be enrolled at
university the fact that Bentham was
extremely short for a 12 year old made
him an even greater curiosity than usual
and he was stared out wherever he went
in addition to developing an
extraordinary intellectual body of
knowledge by the time he was a teenager
Bentham had also built for himself a
strong moral code he recalled I never
told a lie I never in my remembrance did
what I knew to be a dishonest thing his
father placed him under the care of a
personal tutor by the name of Jacob
Jefferson he was a morose and gloomy
person who saw it as his duty to prevent
Jeremy from having anything that even
remotely resembled fun the only thing
that remotely approached one in Jeremy's
life was to play shuttlecock very
irregularly yes even this was
unacceptable to Jefferson and
interrupts the game and usher the boy
back to his books he instilled in
Bentham psyche that any activity that
did not involve educational advancement
was a waste of time while at Oxford
Bentham only received a modest allowance
from his father this meant that he was
forced to incur debt his father was also
concerned that the boy was too timid and
too shy on one occasion while visiting
Oxford James took his son to the Grand
Hall at Christchurch at the time the
students there were all the siblings for
dinner
James instructed his son to walk up down
the aisles and see if he could find any
of the boys that he knew for Jeremy this
was hellish assignment with each
succeeding step he felt closer to
fainting by the time he had finished he
was red with embarrassment and had no
acquaintances to report his father
though thought this was an excellent
strategy for his son to get noticed
further to that goal he bought a silk
gown for Jeremy while the other boys
were playing gallons Bentham found the
instruction Docs had almost as pointless
and uninspiring as he found the
instruction at Westminster he managed at
times to escape the monotony of his
routine with fishing which she was not
particularly fond of he found no
pleasure in the company of any other
students considering the vast majority
of them to be immature morons when he
was sixteen Jeremy's father took him on
a tour of France he was fascinated by
the beauty in the architecture of Paris
being especially impressed by the
wonders of the Palace of Versailles
surely thereafter his father remarried
Jeremy stepmother the former mrs. Abbas
had a strained relationship with Bentham
and he also spoke of her with the lack
of affection in 1766 Bentham took his
master's degree at Oxford with a major
in law to celebrate his graduation his
father gave him the gift of 20 pounds
the following year he left Oxford in his
own estimation his education at the
College had not benefited him James had
intended that Jeremy would use the
opportunities at the college to
establish contacts that he would be able
to exploit upon graduation in order to
make his way up in the world but the boy
had been unable to shake his natural
timidity and he didn't build any
meaningful relationships with people who
were going to help him in the future
[Music]
Bentham was admitted to the bar in 1769
though he never ended up practicing law
he became greatly disappointed with the
English legal code which he considered
to be overly cumbersome and rather
complex his disillusionment was
compounded upon after hearing a series
of lectures by the leading legal
authority of the time Sir William
Blackstone after listening to Blackstone
he decided that he no longer wanted to
practice law instead as he was going to
write about it he would spend his
energies critiquing the existing law and
proposing ways that it could be improved
Bentham took another tour of France with
his father and stepmother in the latter
half of 1769 in 1770 Bentham started
upon his extensive writing career his
first published works were two letters
sent to the London Gazette when he was
23 one of these letters he later said it
was a portrait of my character and my
love affair as Lord Mansfield had been
attacked I showed that there was no
evidence for the story Bentham spent an
inordinate amount of time perfecting
every words that he committed to paper
everything had to be precise his early
writings often contained the seeds of
the ideas that were fully fleshed out in
his more famous later works
[Music]
in July of 1776 the American colonies
issued their Declaration of Independence
the British government did not lower
themselves to issue an official response
however a london-based pamphleteer was
commissioned to publish a rebuttal
the man who was charged with writing
this piece but of course was Jeremy
Bentham however the response was not
published under Bentham's name that was
rather the final chapter of John Linds
answer to the Declaration of
Independence Bentham was a good friend
of Lin's and was living at his house
when Lindh was commissioned to the job
he was delighted to take on the
Americans imprint he proceeded to pull
apart the Declaration ruthlessly
exposing its weak points
he sets the tone in his introduction
declaring the opinions of the modern
Americans on governments like those if
they're good ancestors on which craft
would be too ridiculous to deserve any
notice if like them too contemptible and
extravagant as they be there too not led
to the most serious evils among his many
critiques Bentham ridiculed the idea of
all men being created equal stating that
it gives equal status to the newborn
baby and magistrate he also claims that
the use of the government to ensure the
attainment of life liberty and pursuit
of happiness is an oxymoron as the
exercise of any form of government will
alienate at least one of those
inalienable rights Bentham dismisses the
framers of the Declaration of
Independence is nothing more than a mob
of radicals worse even than the German
anabaptists he concludes with sincere
wishes that these ungrateful and
rebellious people be forced back into
line I think now is the perfect time to
tell you about today's sponsor
brilliance these longer videos they are
made possible because of sponsors like
brilliant so it would mean a lot to me
if you took a moment when you're
finished with this video to go and check
them out you're doing that really does
allow us to keep doing what we do here
at Baia graphics and bringing you these
longer videos so brilliant are a science
learning platform that allow you to
learn through active learning which
summed up is basically the opposite of
that feeling of reading through some
really complex page about some principle
and just having no idea what's going on
because you've never put it into
practice brilliant cover everything from
the very basics do the very complex but
they make it all very very manageable
now you've heard me talk a bunch about
brilliant if you're a regular viewer and
it's a perfect fit for this channel
because hey if you're watching a 20
minute video
on YouTube that's educational you
probably like learning so you're
probably going to be into brilliant as
well recently brilliant I've made an
important update to their mobile app so
that courses can now be accessed offline
so you don't have to worry about having
a solid internet connection to learn
things through their platform also
they've got something called daily
challenges which is where every day you
have a problem to solve it's a great way
to spend maybe five minutes laying like
I say on your commute and getting to
grips with a subject so like I say
brilliant makes even complex concepts
easy to understand they give you
something to see we're short to read
it's very easy to grasp and then you
immediately apply it to a problem
rinse and repeat and suddenly you're
understanding very complex stuff that
you didn't think it would be all courses
are totally interactive so you can
understand probability by playing
blackjack those sorts of things so if
you want to support bio graphics that
would be awesome and get access to all
of brilliance in depth maths and science
courses head over to brilliant org
forward slash biographic so you have 20%
off their annual premium subscription
let's go back to Bentham because we're
about to get into his most famous ideas
and all the weird thing that happened
after he died
having dismissed the Americans Bentham
set his focus on writing about social
and legal reforms in his beloved England
one of his pet projects was a design for
an improved prison building called the
panopticon the design of the structure I
doubt every prisoner in the facility to
be able to be watched by a single guard
without them knowing whether or not they
were under observation Bentham was well
aware that there was no way that a
single watchman can actually keep an eye
on everyone at the same time but the
fact that prisoners didn't know if they
were being watched would according to
Bentham forced them to regulate their
own behavior the panopticon was a
circular building with a watch house in
the centre where a guard could monitor
all of the inmates Bentham described the
design as a mill for grinding rogues
honest in 1791 Bentham published a book
on his panopticon's plants he fully
intended for the prison to be built and
even planned to govern the facility
himself in 1794 he was able to interest
the government of William Pitt in the
idea he was paid 2,000 pounds for his
plans after a number of frustrating
holdups Bentham ended up buying a plot
of lands on behalf of the crown in 1799
from his perspective the site was far
from ideal when he requested more funds
to go buy lands he was told to simply
build a smaller prison from this he
discerned that there was no real
commitment to penal reform on the part
of the government when William Pitt
resigned from Parliament in 1801
enthusiasm for the project waned two
years later it was shut down completely
Bentham he was crushed by the closing
down of his pet project stating they
have murdered my best days
[Music]
Bentham's political philosophy is summed
up in the concept of utilitarianism it
is based on the principle that an action
is right only if it promotes happiness
and wrong if it does not promote
happiness that happiness relates not
only to the instigator of an action but
to the rest of society as well Bentham's
answer to the question what should a
person do is that a person should do
only that which produces the best
consequences Bentham he was not a
professional philosopher as a critic and
shaper of the law he believed that his
utilitarian principle should be the
practical guide by which all people
including the lawmakers in government's
made decisions his underlying principle
was summed up by his contemporary Joseph
Priestley as the greatest happiness for
the greatest number his greatest wish
was that the more makers of society
would use his principle in order to
remake a more equitable and logical
legal framework for society he wrote if
anything could be identified as the
fundamental motivation behind the
development of classical utilitarianism
it would be the desire to see useless
corrupt laws and social practices
changed in determining what was good and
what was bad Bentham believed that the
pursuit of pleasure and the avoidance of
pain were the deciding factors he held
it as a given that pleasure was good and
that pain was bad the fact that a person
is rich or poor black or white male or
female intelligence or dim-witted should
he believed have absolutely no bearing
on their right to enjoy the same level
of pleasure and avoid the same measure
of pain as anyone else in the class
defined society that was England at the
time this was a pretty radical notion
Bentham was never interested in anything
unless it could be practically applied
in society in order to help people to
apply his utilitarian theory he
developed what he called the hedonic
calculus by using it people would be
able to balance out the pleasurable and
painful effects of any proposed action
they had on a calculus includes seven
factors which need to be taken into
account in relation to the pleasure or
pain produced when considering a course
of action these are intensity duration
certainty remoteness extends purity and
fecundity or likelihood that the
sensation will be followed by more of
the same an example of the kunti that
Bentham gave was smiling at a stranger
this may make you feel good for a short
period of time but it may also cause
that stranger to smile
someone else and this could keep going
indefinitely so the sensation would be
repeated many times over purity is the
opposite of fecundity we might get a
temporary feeling of pleasure by
punching someone in the face get the
chances are high that they will punch us
right back in which case we will get to
the opposite sensation so the sensation
is not pure it's quickly diluted so to
speak
in the 1790s Bentham became interested
in helping clean up a notorious area
known as the pool of London this was a
stretch that ran along the River Thames
from London Bridge down to line house it
was the center of crime vice and all
sorts of illegal activity a major
problem was shipboard theft with
merchants losing half a million pounds
of merchandise every year
Bethan worked with a Scottish magistrate
by the name of Patrick Cahoon for a
solution to the problem what they came
out with was the Thames river bill which
was passed into law in the year 1800 it
brought into existence the Thames River
police this force the first police force
in England was specifically designed to
stop theft and looting from ships it was
designed to act as a preventative for
crime which was sort of a new concept at
the time
[Music]
by the 1780s Bentham's writings and
influence had made him an influential
world thinker he was in contact with
many people of note he kept up a lively
communication with Scottish economist
Adam Smith in an attempt to bring about
free-floating interest rates he also was
in communication with the movers and
shakers of the French Revolution however
when things devolved into the mass
terror of wholesale beheadings he
roundly criticized what was happening
there Bentham is remembered as one of
the earliest advocates of animal rights
extending his utilitarian philosophy he
stated that it was not the ability to
reason but rather the ability to feel
which determines who or what was covered
by the pleasure and pain principle
Bentham did believe that animals could
be killed for food or if a person was
defending themselves or others from
attack but only so long as there was no
gratuitous suffering involved Bentham
was also well ahead of his time when it
came to the issue of women's rights in
fact he once stated that it was the
inequality in the treatment of women
that he observed in his youth that first
prompted him to take the role of
lifelong reformer even though he was of
the belief that women were both
physically and intellectually weaker
than men his utilitarian philosophy
prescribes that they should be able to
enjoy equal rights
as he approached his 80s Bentham began
to give serious consideration to his
death and his legacy he wrote detailed
directions regarding what was to be done
with his corpse in 1830 he wrote a paper
in which he instructed the English
physician Thomas southwood smith to
create what he called an auto icon and
this was attached to his will
Jeremy Bentham died on June the 6th 1832
at his home in Westminster in London
according to his instructions his body
was dissected in the presence of his
friends the auto icon was created by
reconstructing the skeleton replacing
the head with a wax model and then
dressing it up in his clothes and
placing it on a seat in the glass case
this ever dream along with the mummified
head of Bentham is still on display at
University College in London so I really
hope you found that video interesting
particularly that last bit I didn't
rather like if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe it got brand new videos
several times a week if you're looking
for more from me why not check out my
other channel called top tens you'll
find that linked to below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]